- [Kevin] All right, welcome everyone.
You've made it to the Mandalay Bay.
So for folks who had trouble
finding it, you made it.
My name is Kevin Luo.
I'm a principal product
manager at AWS Identity,
and I'm joined by.
- [Luke] I'm Luke Kennedy.
I'm a principal engineer
on the AWS IAM team.
- [Kevin] Excellent.
Now before we get started,
even though this is a 300 level section,
I wanna get a sense of who's in the room,
and so by show of hands, who's new to AWS?
You're a new builder.
Like in the last year or so.
Okay, all right then, are
you an experienced builder
so you kind of know your way around?
You can write IAM policies?
Show of hands. Okay, great.
And then how many of you
can write IAM policies
with your eyes closed?
You just know them.
Okay, we got one hand there, two hands.
Luke?
Well, Luke didn't raise his hand
and he helped build IAM, right?
I've been building on AWS for 10 years now
and even I get hung up on it.
So, you know, today
we're gonna talk to you
about IAM Policy Autopilot.
It's a new tool we just launched
that can help accelerate
your workflows today.
You can get started faster with IAM
when you just want to build.
So this is a co-talk.
So we're gonna jump into a scenario here.
So today we're gonna build a microservice
that creates and encrypts S3 buckets
for a multi-tenant service,
and this is really important
because when I have a multi-tenant service
and I onboard customers, I wanna make sure
that there's data isolation
between that, right?
And so I wanna create a
bucket just for that customer,
and then I wanna make
sure I have a KMS key
just for that customer's data.
And so what we're gonna do is
when a new customer signs up,
we'll create a dedicated
KMS key for this customer,
we're gonna create a bucket,
and we're gonna configure a
bucket to use their KMS key.
And so from an architecture perspective,
it's gonna be really simple.
We'll have a Lambda function,
it's gonna accept a customer
ID and name as a parameter.
The first thing we're gonna do
is call KMS and create a key there.
Then we'll create a bucket
and then we're gonna call
the encrypt bucket function.
So with that, let's jump into the code.
All right, so I have my ID open here
and I'll walk you just folks
really quickly through the code
so you know what's going on.
So here we have a
Python-based lambda function,
and at the top I'm importing
some of the clients
that I'm gonna need.
So I'm using the BOTO 3 SDK.
And here you can see that
we're accepting a customer ID
and customer name as a
parameter for the event,
and the first thing we're gonna do
is we're gonna check if the bucket exists
because I don't wanna
create multiple buckets
for that same customer.
And, you know, we're gonna
keep the code simple.
There's a lot of things we could do
to make this super robust, right?
But we're gonna keep the code simple here.
And so I'm calling head
bucket and if it exists,
then we'll just return early.
Otherwise we're gonna go ahead
and create a key, a KMS key,
and we're doing a few
different things here.
You know, we're also adding some tags
so it's easy for me to look it up later.
I'm passing in a key policy
to determine who can manage the key,
I'm gonna call Create Alias
just to make it easier to reference,
and then now I'm gonna go
ahead and call Create Bucket,
and the very last thing we need to do
is call put bucket encryption
to make sure that we're
using the key we just created
to encrypt all objects in that bucket.
So fairly simple.
And so if I'm getting
started, right, let's just say
I'm gonna go create a Lambda function.
So I'll go to the Lambda console here
and we're gonna create a function.
We'll call this SEC351-Demo.
It's a Python function,
and we're gonna create,
and then while that's creating, you know,
we're just starting with the
default execution rule here.
We'll cover that in just a little second.
All right.
So I'm gonna paste my
code in, I'm gonna deploy,
and then what I'm gonna
do is create a test event
so that we could see if it works.
So as we mentioned, we're gonna create,
it's gonna accept a
customer ID, customer name.
Let's do, I don't know, Acne123.
Let's just name it and save it
so it's easier for us to reference,
and so we're gonna test it.
And of course it fails, right?
Because this Lambda
function needs permissions.
So here it's saying
there was access denied
when calling to create key operation
because there's no KMS
tag resource permissions.
And so what does this mean?
So if I go here and I
look at a execution role,
we could do a quick primer
on, you know, what this means.
So for those who are kind of newer to AWS,
IAM stands for Identity
and Access Management
and controls who has access
to what across everything.
Right, and so in this case,
we have a lambda function
which needs an execution role,
which is really just an IAM role,
and then we're gonna define IAM policies
and attach them to that role
to determine what this Lambda
function has access to.
And so in our case, you know,
we need this lambda function
to have explicit permissions
to check if the bucket exists,
create the KMS key, create the bucket,
and then configure bucket encryption.
And so if we go back here,
then we can go and modify
this execution role.
All right, so and this is kind of
it comes with some basic stuff, right?
So this Lambda function
has permissions to go to CloudWatch logs
and create those logs so we could debug,
and so we're gonna attach here.
And so now we're here at this screen.
So how many of us
kind of just use
administrator access here?
I'll just expand this.
Show of hands.
It's okay, be honest.
You're just getting started?
Nobody uses administrator access?
Not for what?
- [Attendee] Not for that.
- [Kevin] Not for Lambda?
Right, because it's really broad.
Well, when I got started
for the first time,
I'm just, I'm like, hey,
I wanna just get this thing to work
and so I used to do this, and
yeah, it's super broad, right?
It allows star, star, but
there's some benefits.
If you're just, you know,
prototyping something,
you're testing something,
you know, it has
permissions and everything.
So when I make an update,
maybe I don't want to use,
you know, I wanna use a different service
or I wanna add DynamoDB to this.
I don't wanna constantly
update my permissions,
and so, you know, this
is nice in the sense
that it reduces some work,
but we have to always scope down earlier
and we all remember to do that.
Okay, so then what's the other option?
So the other option is you could use
some of the other AWS managed policies
that are scoped down some more.
So we use S3, and so I
could look for S3 here.
So how many folks use AWS managed policies
as a starting point for these policies?
Okay, I see about a third of the room.
Okay, and so AWS managed policies
are a much better starting point.
And so here, if I'm looking at S3,
well, I know I need to
create buckets, right?
And so if I look at my options here,
I have read only access or full access.
These other ones are related
to different parts of S3,
and so if I look at read only access,
well, I can't create a bucket.
So then my only other option here
is I could start with read only
and then add the specific
permissions I need, right?
But now I'm jumping in between
things or maybe I start here,
and so okay, it's a better starting point.
It's not the whole world,
but it's still pretty broad
and we have to scope it down.
So let's just say for argument's sake,
we used AWS managed policies.
You know, I just wanna get started.
So we'll do S3 full access
and then we use KMS.
So I'm gonna add the KMS managed policy
that I have available here.
And so we have it.
All right, so now the
function should work, right?
So let's go.
Let's go to the test tab, and it works.
Uh-oh, so let's see what we have here.
So we have an error message
and it says it's a malformed
policy document exception
when calling to create key operation.
The new key policy will not allow you
to update the key policy in the future.
Who knows what happened here?
What was that?
Does anyone know the root cause?
Right, okay, so then we gotta kind of...
Oh, you raised your hand.
- [Attendee] I think we need to have
a resource-based policy on that key.
- [Kevin] You need to have a
resource based policy on a key.
Not quite right.
And so we have to kind of search
around and figure this out.
So I'll save you some time.
It's because we're
missing an IAM permission.
So what we're doing is if
we go back to the code,
when we call create key,
we're passing in a policy.
And so this is saying, hey,
when I create this key,
I want it to have this policy by default.
But to do that you need a KMS
put key policy permission,
and so what this error message is saying
is it's warning you about lockout.
It's saying, hey, because I
couldn't put this key policy,
you're gonna run into a situation
where you're gonna be locked out
and you can't manage this key anymore,
and so that's what this
error message is saying.
But, you know, if you're
just getting started,
you're not familiar, this can
take a lot of time to debug.
And so if I, you know, just to
show you, I'm gonna go ahead
and now I'm gonna have to
create an inline policy
because what we're seeing here
is that AWS managed policies
don't necessarily have
all the permissions you need.
There's a lot of permissions out there
and sometimes you have
to add the ones you know.
So here I'm gonna go to KMS,
and this is about permissions management.
So I'm gonna add the put key
policy, and I'm gonna scope it,
and we're gonna click next.
So, put key policy.
Okay, so now if I go back,
might need some time to propagate.
Let's see what happened here.
Lemme just change this just in case,
but I think it should work.
Next. Save.
That's weird.
All right, well, oh, create alias.
Okay, so it's because
the key already exists.
So let me just change the inputs here
so we're starting fresh.
The specified bucket is invalid.
What is going on?
- [Attendee] Can you zoom in?
- [Kevin] Is it two?
Okay, yeah, I could zoom in.
Specify bucket is invalid.
- [Luke] Do you have a space in your name?
- [Luke] I have a space, but
I wasn't sure in the code.
In the code. I'm sorry.
In the inputs. Sorry.
But it looks like you're right.
Yeah. That's weird.
Well, for the sake of...
This is how you know
it's a real demo, folks.
It's not scripted.
Yeah, so just trust me,
it kind of works there.
So then, okay, what are the other options?
So let's see, it's 2025 and
we're all using coding systems.
I don't need to hand
write my policies anymore.
I have coding assistants
that do that for me.
And so how many of us
here use coding systems?
It's pretty much everyone, right?
I love it.
As a product manager, it's really great
because it's allowed me
to kinda get my ideas
and build prototypes and
kind of really interact
with my engineering teams,
so that's been really great.
And so now, okay, let's try
using a coding assistant,
and so I have my code
here and I have Kiro.
I'm gonna say, hey, generate
an AWS IAM policy for my code.
And so what is Kiro gonna do here?
So it's gonna analyze my code
and it's gonna generate a policy.
So it's reading this Python code.
This file acts as restricted
to a workspace attempted path.
What is it doing?
Okay, I think it figured out
a different way to read it.
So we have an IAM policy here
and it looks like it's got stuff.
So let's take this,
and then we're gonna go
and modify that role.
So I'm gonna delete the
stuff we just added,
and then we're gonna add an inline policy
and so I'm just gonna
paste in what I have.
This is the Kiro-generated policy
and here we see something interesting.
So when you use the IAM console,
it comes with policy validation built in,
which is really great.
So it tells us, hey, is
all this stuff real, right?
Or if I'm doing like AMT pattern,
and so we look at these error
messages, what do we see here?
It says the action S3 head bucket.
I'll zoom in a little bit more.
The action S3 head bucket does not exist,
and indeed it does not exist.
When you call head bucket,
it's actually a list bucket
for the permission.
This other one is interesting.
Put bucket encryption.
That seems like it should work,
but actually the IAM action
is put encryption configuration.
And so if we think about why this is,
why do coding assistance in LMs
tend to struggle with AWS IAM, you know,
they're trained on public information
like documentation, code
examples, et cetera,
and based on that they learn patterns.
And this is actually what humans do too.
We learn patterns.
Oh, I see the create key method call.
So, therefore, the IAM action
is probably KMS create key,
and that's a reasonable assumption
to make most of the time.
But then, you know, they
don't understand things
like hidden dependencies.
So we talked a little bit
earlier about create key,
and I put a policy as a parameter.
Oh, it also needs to
put key policy action,
or there are these naming inconsistencies
like put bucket encryption.
That's the method call,
but the action is put
encryption configuration.
And then it's not always the case
that one method call
requires only one IAM action.
Sometimes it requires more than one.
For example, S3 copy object.
You need, you know,
initially you might write,
oh, the permission is S3 copy object,
but that's actually two.
You need get object and put object,
which makes a lot of sense.
And so if we recap our options here,
you know, we have option one,
which was administrator access.
And for those who are really just kind of,
hey, I'm just trying to blaze through,
I'm in a sandbox environment, great.
It's the fastest way to get started.
And when I'm changing my code,
I'm adding different services,
I'm changing my mind,
I'm gonna need to touch my permissions,
again, it just works.
But of course we know this is super broad,
it has powerful
administrative permissions,
and the security team
wouldn't like that, right?
But it's okay, I'm gonna
scope this down later
and we all remember to do that.
Okay, so then option two
we talked about AWS managed policies
and this is also fast if you
know what you're looking for,
you know what services you're using,
you know if you're using
read or write permissions,
or you're using permissions
that require permission updates,
and this is definitely
a better starting point
than Star Star.
Now it comes with some trade-offs, right?
When you're making code updates,
you're adding new services
or you're changing like
maybe I want to read
from the S3 bucket now.
Well, now you might need to change
which AWS managed policies you use.
And we also learned they
don't necessarily cover
all the possible permissions
like KMS book key call logs here.
And so these are great,
it's a good starting point,
but it's still broad,
and we definitely all
remember to scope this out.
How many people actually go
and scope down these policies
for those who raised their
hand on AWS managed policies?
Do we go and scope that down later?
I see a lot fewer hands.
Don't worry, I won't
tell the security teams.
Okay, and so then we have option three.
Artisanal handcrafted policies.
And this is great, you know,
it's closest to least-privilege.
Luke can write them with his eyes closed.
But it's time consuming
if you're not like Luke
and you didn't help build IAM.
It's time consuming to research
the exact permissions that you need,
and again, we went through that kind
of debugging flow there.
And then also every single time,
because it's least privilege,
every single time you do something
that requires additional
permissions, you have to go back
and modify these permissions,
and so sometimes this can slow things down
and you just wanna build.
Of course, LMs solve that, right?
It's fast and a lot of times
it does work until it doesn't,
and then that continues to
add to that debug cycle.
Additionally, they're
not always deterministic.
They don't always generate
the same policies,
and that, you know, when it
comes to access management,
you really want some determinism there.
And so I want to introduce you
to something we just launched on Sunday
and we made open source.
It's called IAM Policy Autopilot.
It's a command line tool
that can statically analyze your code
and generate policies based
on what your code is doing.
We've also exposed it as an MCP server
so that your coding systems have access
to the same deterministic
policy generation capabilities.
So let me talk a little
bit about how it works.
So step one, we view static code analysis
to parse your code.
So, and we do this all
locally on your machine,
and so here we have the
Lambda function on the left
and we pick out all the SDK operations.
Head bucket, create key,
create alias, and so on.
Then the next step is
we map these operations
to IAM actions.
So one thing we do is
we've actually published
our IAM service reference available.
So I have a URL here.
If you type that in,
you'll get a big JSON blob
of all the IAM actions and conditions
for all the different
services, and this is great.
This is a super helpful reference data.
And recently I think over the last month,
we just launched an enhancement to this
and we added operations
to actions mappings,
and so here's just the JSON snippet here.
And so what this does, it says,
hey, we have this Boto3
create key operation,
and it tells you what are all the actions
that are associated with that.
So here it's saying, okay,
when I call create key from Boto3,
I need the KMS create key action,
the KMS put key policy action,
and the tag resource action.
Now I don't always need them,
but this is kinda like the outer boundary
of what you might need when
you typically call that,
and this is based on actual
service data that we have.
And so now the last
step is we combine that.
So we got the method
calls, we have our lookup
so now we can map out
all the actions we need,
and then we can generate
a policy deterministic
based on that.
Now I will say this policy
is not a real one, right?
I needed it to fit on one screen,
but I'm trying to illustrate that.
You know, based on this we
can now generate a policy.
And so there are three key
benefits with this approach.
The first is it's really deterministic.
You give it the same code
and it generates the
same actions and policies
every single time, and
that's really valuable
when we want to think
about access management.
It's also up to date.
It used the live service
reference data we publish.
If we think about coding assistance,
their training data was
like last Thanksgiving.
Something like that.
You know, there are tools and stuff
that can help keep it up to
date, but here, you know,
we just launched a whole bunch of services
that all those actions are now available
in the service reference data,
and so it has live up to date information.
And it's reliable
because we're using this
service reference data.
You're not gonna see S3 head bucket
as an action that shows up here.
It's all based on real stuff.
Now, you know, we're just
getting started here,
and I do wanna call out some limitations
that you should be aware of.
So today we just generate
identity policies,
and so we're not supporting
kind of cross account use cases
where you might need a
resource-based policy and account
to grant, you know,
access to S3 bucket there.
And these policies, as
I touched on earlier,
it's not necessarily gonna
be the most shrink wrapped
these privileged ones, right?
We do the action mapping here,
and these are typically the actions
associated with that method call.
And so our intention here
is to give you a better starting point
than kind of some of these other
broad options that we have.
And when we looked at some internal data,
we looked at the developers that, like,
actual policies that developers wrote,
and we compared them to
the number of permissions
that IAM policy auto policy generated,
and we found that it generated
just 3% of the permissions
of what's on live running code today.
And so that's meaningful, right?
What's out there is 97% over privileged
even though we all have
good intentions, right?
The other thing is static analysis today
doesn't support automatic
identification of resource names,
and, so you know, you do
wanna scope your resources
down to the specific ones, right?
I don't want to just able to read
from every single S3
bucket in this account,
and so we, you know, you
definitely wanna scope that down
and depending on your journey
and where you are, you know,
it could be something you do later,
or you wanna do right in that moment.
This is something that we
definitely wanna add coming soon.
And then we have that
operation to action mapping,
and it generally catches
the vast majority,
but sometimes there are edge cases
where certain complex
cross service dependencies
might be missing there, right?
I'll give you an example.
Sometimes when you read from
an S3 bucket and encrypted,
you also need KMS permissions there.
So there's some cross service mappings.
And so we're continuously adding to this.
And so I've done enough talking now.
Let's actually see it in action
so I'm gonna pass the mic to Luke.
- [Kevin] I'm gonna take over,
and we'll start by setting
up IAM Policy Autopilot.
So today we're gonna use Kiro,
and first we're going to
get rid of this policy
that we know is wrong,
and we're going to get rid of this session
which gave us the wrong data.
But first we need to set
up IAM Policy Autopilot.
So we're gonna pop over into our terminal,
and IAM Policy Autopilot
has a variety of ways
that we distribute it,
but the easiest one to get
started with is just doing pip.
So we'll just do a pip install
of IAM Policy Autopilot.
And it's that easy.
So now I can just run
IAM Policy Autopilot,
and there it is.
So as you can see, it does have
functionality exposed here,
but today we're gonna focus
mostly on the use case
where you're using it with a
coding assistant in your IDE.
So the first step of that is
setting it up as an MCP server,
and every coding assistant you use
is going to have a different method
of configuring an MCP server.
For Kiro, you click on
the little ghosty icon,
you come down to the
modify your MCP servers,
and you get this nice little configuration
and we're just going to paste
in IAM Policy Autopilot.
Now for those familiar with pip,
you may be familiar with the UV tool,
which allows you to run pip applications.
I'm using UV in this case
so I can get the nice update functionality
that comes with it.
So it'll always update
the pip installation
every time I run the server.
So now I'm gonna save this
and you can see over on
the left that it connected,
and it found all of my tools.
So now, IAM Policy Autopilot
is available to Kiro
as an agent it can use.
So let's go back to our code,
and nothing has changed here,
but we're going to try to
generate a new policy now.
Get rid of that session. Start over.
So I'm gonna ask Kiro once again
to please create an IAM
policy for this script.
Now this is the fun part of the demo
because this is the non-determinism
that you get with any model-based thing.
So we're gonna hope
that Kiro behaves today
and plays to our script.
So it starts, reads our
file and says, you know,
hey, I wanna scope this appropriately.
So tell me what region
and what account ID you want to access.
So we're gonna use US-west-2,
and my account ID is
also saved right here.
And so it's chosen to
call IAM Policy Autopilot.
It's gonna pass these
parameters, you know,
we're just gonna vibe today
and not really read those
and just say run.
All right, and it spits out this policy,
and here's a short description.
Would you like me to save this file?
Yeah, sure. Please.
And let's look at these permissions.
So we'll start where we've got
these S3 permissions at the
top, and most importantly,
I don't see head bucket.
I don't see any permissions
that don't exist.
It did give me the full
closure permissions
I may need for S3 based on the script,
but I know they're all gonna be correct
and they're gonna work.
Here's my KMS permissions.
You can see that the region is filled in,
the account ID is filled in.
Reese's are wildcards
because these are all create operations,
and so we can't scope
them to a specific thing.
But now we have our policy,
and so if we wanna test out that policy,
instead of going the long way,
I'm going to use cloud
formation to do this.
I encourage everyone
to use some type of
infrastructures code set up
to manage their entities
across their account,
and today I'm gonna use cloud formation
and Kiro's gonna write it for me.
Sorry, I need to accept those changes.
Okay, so now Kiro has everything it needs.
It has the code, it knows that
if it's gonna make a Lambda,
it needs to run that using an IAM role
So it's probably gonna
create that role too.
Let's see what it spits out.
All right, so here's my code.
That's great.
And here is my policy, and as we can see,
it is exactly the same
policy that we generated.
It just took that in from the
file and put it into here.
Using cloud formation,
you can fill in variables
and do substitutions
for created resources.
Our particular policy didn't have that
because we're doing crates,
but this is one of those cases
where using something like infrastructure
as code with IAM Policy Autopilot
gives you a nice better together setup
where it starts to lease privilege
down to the resources you need
because it knows to fill
in the variables at runtime
and at creation time.
So we have this now.
We're going to ask it
to deploy our template.
All right, and go.
Okay, so while that's running,
we can talk a little bit about the CLI.
So as Kevin mentioned,
IAM Policy Autopilot does work as a CLI,
but also happens to have
an MCP server endpoint exposed to it.
When you use it as a CLI,
it works just the same.
So I can say IAM Policy Autopilot,
and then let's do generate policies,
and then I'm in the same directory
so we'll just say my customer onboarding.
And I run that, and it
immediately spits out
that same policy.
And let's make it a little
easier to read for everyone
so we can see it is in fact the same.
And that's the determinism
that you get from this tool
that it's always gonna give you
the same policy for your code.
The CLI allows you to
easily integrate this
into other CI flows that you may have.
So if you have a existing
flow that takes your code,
does some builds on it,
we can now have that
integrate with this and spit
out your policies as you go.
All right, let's go back
to cloud formation here.
It says it's still running, but we can...
Oh, it says it just finished
but let's check on it just to be sure.
Hey, it's good. Perfect.
Okay, so now we need to
test that lambda function
to make sure it works
because I made these claims
that we have the write permission.
Let's enforce that then back it up
by saying let's invoke this function.
Okay, it's gonna ask to run the Lambda.
We're gonna say run.
You can see here in the terminal
it ran the CLI command, and status 200.
And Kira wants to run it
again for some reason.
We don't know why, but
we'll just tell it to stop.
Okay, so that's great.
I had some code, I ran it, it worked,
it made a function that was good,
but now let's say I want
to iterate on this code
and I want to, instead
of just creating the key,
creating the bucket, I also
wanna get a notification
that this is done because I wanna do
some further events on that.
So let's add SQS as a notification queue.
So I got another script
here, I'm gonna pull over
because I don't have time to type this,
but here's the same script.
I've added an SQS client,
I've given it a QURL,
and down at the very end,
after we create the bucket
and put the KMS configuration on it,
we now send a message
to SQS to let us know
that we just created
all the infrastructure
we needed for this new customer,
and here's the basic
identifiers we need for it.
So from here, if we go back to our chat
and say please generate
a CFN template for...
I can't spell. Apologies.
For the current file.
It's gonna go through
the same process again,
it's going to create my template.
Now, I didn't explicitly ask it
to update the permissions on it,
and so it's probably gonna just pick up
the IAM policy JSON it used here.
It'll wait for the agent to do its thing.
Still going.
Okay, unfortunately, Kiro was very helpful
and decided to add this permission.
Let's unfix that.
So we're gonna come down here,
we're going to just remove this.
We all know that it's needed,
but now for the sake of the argument,
let's say that Kiro decided
not to mess with our policy, okay?
And now please deploy.
Okay.
Lemme go through again
with the new change set.
- [Kevin] And while it's
running here, so in this case,
Kiro did add the right permissions
and we did probably this dry run,
I don't know, 10 times, Luke?
- [Luke] At least two dozen times.
- [Kevin] And on, you know,
going back to that non-determinism,
it did it some of the time,
but a lot of times it didn't.
So, you know, you're kind of
coming down to chance on this.
So here we're gonna simulate
an example of what happens
if it didn't add that permission,
or sometimes ourselves.
We're all humans too, right?
And sometimes we deploy
something and we're like,
oh, I forgot to update the execution role.
And so now we can see, you
know, IAM Policy Autopilot
includes additional functionality
to help you with this as well.
- [Luke] So we see a case
where cloud formation's just-
- [Kevin] Taking its time.
- [Luke] Taking its
time, it's kind of stuck.
I have a feeling that
stack will never finish
so we'll try again from...
Oops.
From a different template.
We're doing a little
bit of a cooking show.
Anyone watch that?
You pull it from the oven.
All right.
Okay, so here we go.
It's deploying.
And we know this is gonna break.
So we know that it's going
to create the template,
it's gonna create an IAM user,
it's gonna create an IAM role.
That role is not gonna have
the required SQS permissions.
That's intended.
So we're gonna execute
the Lambda function.
Now we already deployed that.
Okay, so let's run that function.
Okay, and we can see
there is an error here.
Oops.
And that error is the KMS key yard exists.
Let's try a different input.
Okay, so now we're using
customer bouncy pancake,
and okay, look, we got a
message saying, as we expected,
we do not have permission
to do this thing.
So this is where IAM Policy Autopilot
has additional functionality
that we can look at
these messages and say,
hey, you don't have
permission to do this thing.
Why don't you fix that for me?
And this is how we can do a
full agentic flow with this.
By having the ability to analyze,
hey, I got an error, can
you go fix it for me?
And it shows instead
to modify the template.
So let's try this again.
Okay, now it realizes,
hey, I have a tool to fix these errors
so let's try running that.
And this tool allows us to look
at an access denied message
and say, hey, I know
what this resource is,
I know what this principle is,
I can generate a policy
that's gonna fix this
and put all the necessary permissions in.
This is a simple case because
it's just SQS send message,
but if it was a more complex case
where it had dependent actions,
IAM Policy Autopilot would also add those.
So now I'm gonna tell it
to deploy it to my account.
It's going to invoke a tool
that I apparently just
trusted all the way,
and so now it is deployed
in a policy on my account
to give me those additional permissions,
and so it wants to test
the function again,
and we can say run.
Now let's get to the
bottom here and we can see,
oh, now it passed and
there's our valid response
coming out of Lambda.
- [Kevin] And it might be
important to talk about
why this is really useful.
So here we have kind of
like a one-off instance,
but with these agents,
you want them to go run off by themselves.
I wanna say, hey, go
complete this task for me
and I'm gonna go walk
away, grab a cup of coffee,
and then come back.
And so with this, you
know, it's easy enough
for a human to go, hey,
okay, this error message,
I need to add this missing thing.
But if I'm walking away,
I'm not supervising it,
I want my coding assistant in Kiro
to be able to do that myself.
And so now it has the tools
to be able to do that,
and let's say sometimes
you have layered access
denied errors, right?
You have one that shows
up, you fix it, you run it,
another one shows up,
and so for humans it's kind of tedious.
But now by exposing this as a tool,
this coding assistant can
go and unstuck itself,
and so that's kind of the power
on why we expose this
capability as one of the tools.
Okay, cool.
So I'm gonna do a quick recap here.
So we showed you how to
use IAM Policy Autopilot
to generate policies from your code,
and we showed it that when you combine it
with a coding assistant
and the findings of
infrastructure as code,
it can do things like do
the variable substitution
for scoping down by resources
and so there's a really
great better together story.
We also talked to you a little bit
about that fixed access
denied workflow, right?
And so this empowers your coding system
to get itself unstuck, right?
It's the same tools that, you know,
we ourselves would do if we looked at
the access denied error,
and we did this all
without broad permissions
like administrator access,
or AWS managed policies,
or just S3 Star even,
and it was deterministic.
It only used real IAM
actions and services,
and it's up to date.
Now, you know, we're just getting started.
So we are only supporting
identity policies today
and it's not guaranteed to
be least privilege, right?
So there's still some scoping down,
but now you have a much
better starting point.
We talked a little bit
about how policy autopilot
generates 3% of permissions
that kind of developer policies are today.
And then we're working on adding in
the static analysis support
to automatically identify your resources
so it would just only
get better over time.
And so I have a call to action here.
We've open sourced this for a reason.
We wanna collect your feedback,
we wanna do the development in the open,
and so please go visit the
GitHub repository, clone it.
We built it in Rust,
which we love very much,
and if you have feedback
or if you have questions,
feel free to engage with us there.
You know, we're always
planning to improve it,
and keep on the lookout for that.
All right, so with that I
have my obligatory thank you.
Luke and I will hang out here
if you have some one-on-one questions.
So, happy to take 'em,
or we can do a group
discussion here upfront.
Otherwise, this is your reminder
to please complete the
survey in the mobile app.